more than 100,000 people have traveled
to lake iseo in northern italy for a
chance to stroll across christos latest
creation
the floating piers
its massive it's it's hard to describe
we're so excited it's like walking on
water it's wonderful I want to walk
barefoot
it must be great Christos canvas is the
landscape is paint fabric his art is
ephemeral the floating peers will only
exist for 16 days and nights the
Bulgarians born artist has had this
vision of a floating walkway for more
than 40 years
he's implemented at using 220,000
plastic cubes on the day before the
opening his team stretched a hundred
thousand square meters of cloth over the
entire structure the fabric changes
color depending on the weather and time
of day a detail created by the artist
this is extremely physical you know
because you do not talk you don't walk
you there and you're on the project you
move by the project physically and you
need to make effort to walk and to to
see all these things only on constant
motion you personally by the moving of
the water at 7:40 a.m. on Saturday the
first visitors were allowed onto the
walkway Cristo wanted an opening without
any ceremony he and his team came from
the other side only to flee before the
visitors and journalists
the walkway is three kilometers long and
16 meters wide it connects the mainland
to monte isola island and leads to the
small privately owned island of san
paulo a fabric covered from a nod also
runs a long part of the shore of the
island
but it's all proving to be a bit much
for the small population of one te soda
its bars ran out of drinks on the very
first day but special socks for walking
on the piers are turning into a popular
souvenir we're grateful to Christo I
hope he's made Monte Azul a famous in
our 42 years of business we've never
seen such Magnus the content of crowds I
hope we can manage it it's incredible
the installation costs 16 million euros
Christo financed it himself as he does
with all his projects through sales of
his drawings and photos it's the first
large-scale project he's created without
his late wife jean-claude who died six
years ago with me all the time really
for me John could never pass she's all
the time with me of course she was
incredible intellect enormous critical
person I miss her all the time
and when we have a problem and I always
have what Jean what we say now
access to the walkway is free but
visitors should be prepared for long
lines only 11,000 people can be on the
walkway at the same time to prevent
unintended dips in the lake amazing in
two weeks everything will disappear can
you imagine that an artist that doesn't
want to keep his work it's just like
happening applause for the artist as
Christo cruises around his floating
peers the project is the main focus of
his life at the moment
basically for 16 days I will not see
anybody except being my project and I
welcome friends but I will not go any
other place not living like you say be
here with the project a storm is looming
the walkway is cleared when a storm
threatens and then the floating piers
can be seen the way Christo first
envisioned them without masses of people
a striking man-made installation located
in one of Europe's most stunning
landscapes
you